vielleicht habt ihr schon mal vom us
raumfahrt unternehmen rockend lab gehört
es bietet kommerzieller raketen
vorgehens alan 50 flüge pro jahr sollen
es schon bald sein bei dem
beispielsweise forschungssatelliten in
ihrer umlaufbahn abgesetzt werden können
und dieser plan läuft ganz gut der
ersten starts waren erfolgreich welche
technik steckt dahinter
wie hoch sind die kosten und bedeutet
dass tatsächlich eine neue ära in der
raumfahrt
ihr habt euch dieses super spannende
thema öfter bei whatsapp gewünschte
bekommt ist deshalb und zwar alle fragen
zum thema beantwortet herzlich
willkommen bei pixum science fiction
es geht um die zukunft der raumfahrt und
dieses mal ausnahmsweise nicht um elon
musk space is open für business so
lautet das motto des privaten
raumfahrtunternehmens rocket lab mit dem
ziel mit weltraumflügen geld zu machen
wurde es 2006 gegründet und seitdem
entwickelt das unternehmen mehrstufige
trägerrakete und antriebssysteme die
satelliten in den weltraum befördern
künftig sollen pro jahr etwa 50
kommerzielle flüge angeboten werden also
etwa einer pro woche das ist eine menge
im jahr 2009 startete die erste höhen
forschungsrakete von roccat lab ins all
sie erreichte mit ihrem 60 kilogramm
eine höhe von 120 kilometern und konnte
eine nutzlast von zwei kilogramm
befördern
die nächste entwicklungsstufe wurde dann
mit der elektron rakete erreichte ihr
habt vielleicht schon einmal davon
gehört 150 kilogramm soll sie in die
erdumlaufbahn bringen doch der erste
start der rakete mit dem namensschild
testing im mai 2017 gegen schief sie
hatte den geplanten hobbit nicht ganz
erreicht der zweite test im jahr 2018
dagegen war ein grund zum jubeln
die cube satz wurden erfolgreich in die
erdumlaufbahn gebracht kurz zur
erklärung das sind nano satelliten die
oft auch als helden des weltraums
bezeichnen wenn sie sind preiswert und
klein und spielen deswegen bei der
erforschung des weltalls eine immer
größere rolle egal ob die überwachung
von asteroiden die der erde gefährlich
werden könnten oder beim mars missionen
konkret handelt es sich bei dieser
mission mit dem namen swiss testing um
den erdbeobachtungssatelliten darf
pioneer und um 2 uhr zwei satelliten die
wetterdaten erfassen sollen und zudem
auch die aufgabe haben schiffe zu
tracken rocket lab hat sogar einen
eigenen raum fahrten bahnhof und zwar
auf der neuseeländischen halbinsel na ja
das ist tatsächlich der weltweit einzige
weltraumbahnhof in privatbesitz von dort
waren die beiden flügel losgegangen
das erfolgsergebnis von anfang des
jahres lässt das unternehmen große
visionen haben raumflüge könnten
deutlich billiger werden als bislang
pro stadt werden kosten von etwa 4,9
millionen us-dollar kalkuliert dass in
etwa 4,4 millionen euro
das ist ein absolutes schnäppchen
triebwerke werden beispielsweise durch
3d drucker hergestellt und so konnten
die kosten bereits jetzt gesenkt werden
weitere elektromagneten die jeweils 150
kilogramm in den
mitbringen könnten sind in der
produktion spezialisiert sind sie voll
und ganz auf leichte ladungen wie eben
kommunikationssatelliten die firmen
nutzen um naturkatastrophen zum beispiel
vorherzusagen oder die meere zu
beobachten also ganz kleine lasten aber
oft reicht das eben doch die angepeilten
50 raumflüge pro jahr könnten
theoretisch sogar noch getoppt werden
denn die lizenz erlaubt 120 doch selbst
wenn das unternehmen nur die 50 starts
pro jahr schaffen würde könnte sich so
ein teil des marktes erobern rocket lab
erhofft sich beispielsweise aufträge von
der nasa im januar twitterte das
unternehmen jedenfalls today maxe
beginning of new area in commercial
access to space ja wenn ihr kein video
zum thema zukunft der raumfahrt und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp und in
anderen messengern nur dann verpasst er
kein video den die abo box auf youtube
die ist ja immer ein bisschen lückenhaft
über die messenger erfahrt ihr von mir
auch noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und dann geht es
automatisch weiter und zur begrüßung
habe ich ein kleines goodie noch dazu
gepackt und am besten auch mein
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren das geht hier
dafür hat er das neueste aus der social
media wird aktuell die anhörung von mark
zuckerberg vor dem europäischen
parlament aber nicht die glocke
vergessen also ich mach's nochmal genau
hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken fällt in heavy
die revolution der raumfahrt ansonsten
bis dann bleibt